It's easy to find yourself scrolling through
endless titles on Netflix without ever picking
anything.
But that doesn't mean the streaming platform
has nothing good to offer: you just need to
know where to look.
If you're in the mood for a good action movie
you haven't seen a million times, here are
some hidden gems waiting for you on Netflix.
13 Assassins
If you're a fan of Audition or Ichi the Killer,
here's another classic action movie from Takashi
Miike. 13 Assassins is less brutal than those
earlier films but was favorably compared to
Seven Samurai, which is about the highest
praise a samurai film can get.
Taking place near the sunset of feudal Japan,
a group of samurai gather together to defeat
a sinister lord before he takes the throne.
With a 96 percent rating on Rotten Tomatoes,
this might become a new action favorite.
Big Trouble in Little China
It's hard to go wrong with an '80s action
movie starring Kurt Russell.
Big Trouble in Little China stars Russell
as Jack Burton, a man who goes into the mythical
underworld of Chinatown to save a green-eyed
damsel.
The movie has tons of humor and great '80s
action.
If you like John Carpenter films, especially
Escape from New York, you'll wonder why it's
taken you so long to watch Big Trouble in
Little China.
Plus it features a great cheesy theme song
from John Carpenter's band.
What's not to love?
Déjà Vu
Tony Scott didn't always get as much praise
as his older brother Ridley, but he brought
us some fantastic films.
The man behind True Lies and the '80s staple
Top Gun got together an A-list cast for the
2006 film Deja Vu, an underrated film that
Netflix has been hiding right under your nose.
Denzel Washington stars as Doug Carlin, an
investigator tasked with solving a deadly
bombing in New Orleans.
He's given a new piece of technology that
can gaze back four days into the past to help
with the investigation, but he becomes obsessed
with the idea of actually traveling through
time to stop the tragic event from happening.
It's a little sci-fi, a little action, and
all awesome.
The Hunter
Ever wanted to watch Willem Dafoe hunt for
an extinct tiger in the wilds of Tasmania?
Well, The Hunter has just made your dreams
come true.
This unusual action film combines science,
exotic locales, and rich character depth to
create a really intriguing action movie.
If you're looking for a slower-paced but extremely
well-acted action adventure, The Hunter is
just the ticket.
Lucky Number Slevin
This quirky crime comedy flew under the radar
on its release, but Lucky Number Slevin is
full of twists, turns, and distracting fun
that'll keep you watching to the end.
It's clever, funny, and has an amazing cast
that includes Morgan Freeman, Bruce Willis,
Lucy Liu, and Ben Kingsley.
With a clever script and slick visual style,
Lucky Number Slevin is surprisingly entertaining.
The Finest Hours
Based on a true story, this tale of a daring
1952 Coast Guard rescue received some pretty
positive reviews, but kind of sank after its
initial release.
Maybe because The Finest Hours is pretty generic
for a title, but this real-life tale starring
Star Trek's Chris Pine is full of thrilling
moments and moving drama.
So before The Finest Hours slips from your
memory again, give this fine historical drama
a try.
Alive
This gripping drama is based on the true story
of a Uruguayan rugby team struggling to survive
in the Andes after a plane crash.
After only 25 people live through the initial
accident, the team members have to resort
to desperate measures to stay alive.
If you haven't already guessed, yes, this
is the movie where the survivors end up eating
each other.
But it's not a horror film.
Watching these people grasp at hope through
the very worst conditions is harrowing, and
although the movie sounds kind of depressing,
it's actually an uplifting tale of survival
and the unbelievable strength of mankind — not
to mention a roller coaster ride of sheer
adrenaline.
Super
Just in case two installments of Guardians
of the Galaxy wasn't enough to satisfy your
love of James Gunn films, Netflix has a classic
waiting for you.
Before you watch Super, Gunn's first superhero
film, you should know that it's a dark comedy.
Very dark.
That said, it's definitely a visually unique
take on superheroes.
Starring Rainn Wilson and Ellen Page, Super
is about a man who decides to dress up as
a superhero to save his ex-wife...who doesn't
really want to be saved.
It may not have the budget of Guardians, but
you can see Gunn's flare for action and irreverent
humor shine through.
Trollhunter
This surprisingly unique film follows a group
of people on a quest to find real trolls in
the frozen tundra of Norway.
After they find out that the existence of
trolls has been covered up by the Norwegian
government, they make it their duty to capture
one of the elusive monsters on film.
This is no Troll 2.
These trolls look amazing and don't have to
turn humans into plants to eat them.
Shot like a documentary, the film is often
hilarious, though not without its tense moments.
Moira MacDonald, film critic at the Seattle
Times, wrote, "Those fog-draped fjords provide
a distractingly pretty backdrop to this tale
of mysterious, massive creatures who roam
the forest by night, searching for Christians
on whom to munch."
It's safe to say that you're not going to
find a better movie about massive monsters
eating religious folk.
Zombeavers
Don't worry: Zombeavers is completely aware
that it's a movie about zombie beavers.
Thankfully, it's a fun horror parody that
makes the idea of undead beavers as funny
as it could possibly be.
Critic Tim Brayton called it "the funniest
horror-comedy since, at the very least, The
Cabin in the Woods."
If you want a campy, diverting comedy that's
full of laughs and gross-out gags, Zombeavers
is exactly what you're looking for.
Welcome to the Punch
Starring Mark Strong and James McAvoy star
as a criminal and cop who team up to uncover
a conspiracy, Welcome to the Punch is straight-up
action in the best possible way.
The solid casting choices lend a bit of seriousness
and depth of character to the story, but let's
all be honest: this is a movie you watch for
awesome chase scenes and gun fights.
Welcome to the Punch is pretty violent, but
you'd probably expect that from a film that
invites you to a beating in the title.
Last Knights
A cast that stars Clive Owen and Morgan Freeman
usually means a movie worth watching.
Add in castles, swords, and revenge, and you
have yourself a fine action film.
Now, the critics weren't especially kind to
Last Knights, but the New York Times thought
Bonnie and Clyde was an overly violent, pointless
piece of cinema, so why listen to critics?
Last Knights probably won't stand the test
of time like Bonnie and Clyde, but if Game
of Thrones reruns aren't doing it for you,
or if you just like hearing the soothing tones
of Morgan Freeman while people are killed
with swords, Last Knights is worth a watch.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!